- Have a seat
(audience applauds)
- Hey guys.
- [Kelly] I missed you
- I missed you too
- [Kelly] I feel like we,
we've had a break or something.
- I know.
- I love when you come on here.
- I love coming here.
- Oh wait pause, lick teeth.
- Mm.
- [Kelly] See, I'm a real friend.
- I don't wear a lot of
make up, unless I come here
I gotta look good.
(laughing)
- I don't wear make up unless I'm here so
Alright, So have y'all met before?
I didn't know if you-
- We haven't.
- No, this is the first time.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay, awesome.
- I mean
- I'm like Jesus and
bringing people together so.
- Laurence is very handsome
- Oh well, he's
(audience cheering)
- Not bad to look at.
- You see I always wear make
up so people will say that.
(Kelly laughing)
You guys never wear it, I always wear it.
(laughing)
- Did y'all ever sneak
into like R rated movies?
I was thinking, cause
we were talking about it
earlier and I was like,
did y'all ever do that?
Did you ever sneak in?
- Yes.
- Yeah,
I mean I was always the person
- I only did once.
- Well I was, usually
it was from the blockbuster,
back when you had to
- Oh my god,
- find the movie
- you just said blockbuster.
- I know I would watch the
movies that my friends weren't
allowed to watch.
And then I would tell them
what happened in that movie.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God. I love it.
- It was a different time.
Like I remember Crocodile Dundee
was scandalous because she was,
- Oh!
- Yeah, she was in that
- With the bathing suit
- The bathing suit and
the crocodile came out.
- Yeah, and I was all
like, I like this movie.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- I love crocodiles.
- You used to tell them the R
rated versions of the movie?
- Yeah, I would tell people,
- Wow
- what happened. So I was a popular kid.
(laughing)
- Well, today is MLK day.
So what does Dr. King, like,
what does this mean to you?
- I mean, you know, he's historical,
his words are so powerful, you know,
you listen back to those speeches.
You're still moved by those words.
- Still inspired
- Yes, still inspired.
Cause you know, fighting for equality at
a time when it's desperately
needed and it's still needed.
It's good to have those
reminders now that you know,
the fight continues for quality and,
- And what amazing footprints to leave?
Like what a legacy like
for all of us to follow,
- Without a doubt.
- [Kelly] and still follow.
(audience clapping)
Well, I have to ask you
this cause I heard about it
and I think it's maybe one of
the most redneck things ever.
- Uh oh,
- Is it true that your mom won a
free tour of the Frito-Lay factory?
- I mean,
(laughing)
- I don't want to brag about my childhood,
(audience laughing)
but yes, she.
- Like, I love that they give tours.
- It was like a public access
channel that was doing like a,
some sort of fundraiser.
- Oh my God,
- And you could like
call in and you could win
certain prizes, and she won a tour
of the local Frito-Lay factory.
(Kelly laughing)
- And most people would be like, what?
And we were like, (claps)
chips.
(audience laughing)
- It's a good chip.
- Freedom pie is good.
- Yeah and it ended up being
like the Willy Wonka factory.
But for chips, like warm
chips, you eat the chips.
As they came out of the oven.
- I love how she said it was like warm.
It took her back for a minute.
(laughing)
Her mouth is watering right
now. She was like, it was warm.
- I don't know if you guys
have ever had a warm sun chip.
- You know, see, see.
- But it's a next level.
- Hey, those are good.
- Yeah.
- Wait, so your, your comedy
tour is called, Hey y'all.
- Yeah.
- So Hey y'all tour.
So how's it been going?
- It's been amazing.
I had a Netflix hour special
come out and I got to make that
leap to theaters on this tour.
- Wow, yeah.
- And yeah.
- That's so cool.
(audience clapping)
- People been coming out
like crazy to the show.
- Well we're dying
- I know.
- For contact first of all,
And to laugh.
- Yeah, I think people
need to laugh right now.
They're feeling that more than ever,
you can see the stress kind
of come off people as the show
goes, and so it's just, it's
been a level of laughter.
I don't think I've ever
experienced before from the fact
that it has been such a difficult time
- Yeah.
- for so many people.
So I'm really grateful.
This tour was supposed to
happen a year and a half ago.
People have held onto their
tickets. We keep adding shows.
So, I'm so,
- Super blessed.
- So blessed.
- Yeah, isn't it a blessing like because
we all get to experience this,
in, in our own forums.
But like you just mentioned,
like for people to come to a
show and you see that release
and that escapism that they
get to experience just for that
moment, you know,
- Yeah.
- we get to provide that.
It's the coolest thing to be a vessel for.
- It's the greatest, I mean, to,
to get like y'all were talking
about earlier to do something
that you love and to
get, to pay your bills.
- Yeah exactly.
- I mean, that is the
ultimate dream truly.
- Yeah,
(audience clapping)
- And we all know what it's
like to really not have money
while trying to get this job.
- Oh,
(Kelly laughing)
It takes a long time to
be able to pay the bills.
For sure.
- Yeah, cause you're like,
put in a lot of work.
- Woo, electricity I mean I need that.
- [Laurence] Ultimate,
it's the ultimate thing
after eating a warm Frito-Lay right?
(laughing)
- That, I mean it's just warm Frito-Lay,
- [Kelly] Every time,
- It's so warm.
- Laurence you're going
to want some more chips.
- I'm thinking about it right now.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] I'm thinking about
Frito pie, it sounds awesome.
- Oh Frito pie is so good too.
- [Kelly] It's so good, for your thighs.
- You just take chips and
put a bunch of stuff on it.
- And they're warm.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And then they're warm.
- Then it's warm.
(laughing)
- Put them in the microwave
(audience clapping)
- Cause I don't have a chip oven.